you know that nbc has these public
service announcements that they air from
time to time
you know what these things are they
always get some celebrity on the network
to
to give a good message out there to to
people you know what i mean to drive
safe or don't do in school stay in
school don't do drugs well
they started shooting these holiday
public service announcements
just for december and uh they asked me
to do one
and i said fine so i'm kind of excited
with the way it came out it's going to
start airing pretty soon
liz could we show the people my brand
new holiday
public service announcement
let's face it we all get christmas gifts
we're not crazy about
but this christmas if you unwrap a
present that just isn't that great
don't let it show on your face smile
broadly
and tell them it's just what you wanted
then
when their back is turned chuck it at
the base of their skull as hard as you
can they'll never see it coming
merry christmas
i just think that's going to help unless
it sucks when they won't know that
right yeah yeah uh i'm gonna jot that
one down actually uh
you know they asked me to i know he shot
one how'd it come out uh well
let the audience be the judge
how do you handle a relative who drinks
too much on the holidays
how do you tell someone you love that
he's had way too much liquor
and might just embarrass himself just
tell him flat out
be honest and direct if i get pissed off
and hit you
forgive me i'm drunk
[Music]
that's a real nice one can you help was
that your uh
guy huh what the conan andy
yeah well i did a special holiday public
service announcement too
well max that's that's that's terrific
yeah yeah very proud of it uh liz
can we show my public service
announcement
you want to know what's worse than
getting a stupid present
getting eight stupid presents being
jewish
sucks
that's just sold out his people when
you're laughing
i just i just want to know what his
mother's reaction is
oh man oh boy i'm into the beating of
your life all right we're gonna take a
little break and then when we come back
a very funny guy and a fa a good friend
of ours i was gonna say a pal and then i
started to say friend it was gonna come
out
foul or frau ladies and gentlemen colin
quinn will be with us